entre nous si vous pouviez changer
quelque chose dans votre carrière ce
serait quoi
bush humaine rien rien vous a rien du
tout jacques if vous peut-être vidéo gag
non non est-ce que vous avez regretté
parce que lui bernard et un jour et moi
c'est ce jour là que j'ai aimé à la
folie c'est un jour et la féline
interview il a balancé sur tous les
agendas
même de toutes les autres chaînes il a
balancé sur tout le monde s'est lâché je
sais pas s'ils avaient mangé je confie t
il sans ironie je crois qu'il a pris un
bourrin bull type après est ce que vous
regrettez sa troisième vous aviez une
place de choix sur t on plus rien du
jour au lendemain non parce que c'est
pas vous savez la vie c'est pas la télé
lyon a bien voyagé envie d'être heureux
au quotidien ici ça me gonfle mais je me
barre et comme les gens étaient
malhonnêtes avec moi je leur ai dit en
pleine poire je suis parti je suis resté
trois mois au chômage mon cher mathieu
mois et il n'est pas du tout à ses 15
ans au chômage
je trouve bien un mois de façon je dois
ton job alors on a bien su renoncer vous
êtes partout la amy au rwdm vous êtes
oui par exemple hier annie motiver tout
le tournage même rfm ce oui le week end
et point soleil a au calibre c'est
facile de les approvisionner tous nos
dents lunettes
et mon quad c'est nettoyer des cabines
ça c'est pas tous les jours
c'est pourquoi récente du v qui la suit
si les limougeauds région j'y vois un
rien puisqu'on apprend même de ses
erreurs donc il faudra la famille merci
la catéchèse
non mais malheureusement toi c'est pas
le cas tu as fait un paquet d'erreurs et
à rien a primé
[Applaudissements]
je vous dis la vérité
moi je suis pas venu ici pour ça je ne
sais pas comment c'était des spectateurs
moi je suis venu ici on a mis en drapeau
alors si vous pouviez respecter un petit
peu franchement c'est vrai le gardien du
club house on va partir tout de suite en
parcours là il ya des cas dit oui alors
oui et donc si vous avez lui répond on
va juste je souhaite le tiers de mes
fans
cette pauvre ben haim lui tient même
demain demain car hier à wave à un garde
le tir mais ça se passe quoi un tiers de
bouffe je suis pas sûr
[Applaudissements]
ne croyez pas si bien dire j'ai audio il
ya le patron de sce vite qu'ils aiment
envoyer un sms indique qu'il a un projet
pour vous oui qui s'appelle miaou
[Rires]